hello citizens of the reject nation we are we are
we are the reject of the nation all right guys we
got the dc comic con or the warner brothers one
going on right now johnny boys with us goose
is with us today a rooster a comic book movie
aficionado friend over here hey gordon guys guys
we are going to watch the trailer today for sam
fury of the gods what i really appreciate right
now is if you could leave a like shazam that like
button also subscribe and click the notification
bell that we can get notified whatever else we
are covering for the rest of comic con today i
also wanted to give a quick mention today that we
have recently partnered up with heavy spoilers and
screen crush for a one-stop nerd shop called
zero edition where you can get all of our high
quality apparel we got plenty of reject inspired
apparel to represent your pride as a citizen of
the reject nation we're currently working with our
artists on even more designs right now and right
now we've got several stranger things inspired
designs and recently we did one meets one equals
one anyway guys you can go support us by checking
out shop0edition.com anywho let's get into this
boys thank you for helping me out with
those talking points let's get to it
i'm an idiot
it's show time i don't deserve these
powers what am i even contributing wow
there's already a superhero with a
red suit with a lightning bolt on it
aquaman is literally huge and he's
so manly and batman it's so just me
wow
that's nice i feel like a fraud it doesn't
matter um anyway a wizard gave me superpowers
and then everybody got super powers
was everyone going to fight crime okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their own thing
and i'm the only one trying to keep it together
you understand i'm a pediatrician
business listen to me billy the
fate of your world depends on it
look i might not have as much experience
as you because i'm not super old like you
that's the furious movies
lady it's all about family
now where's jesus family guys that was a signal
did i not just pitch a short idea just now
ah cool get together yo i will not survive this
i don't know how we fight powers like this
holy crap i think i know how to
fix this dude but i really don't
everyone can be worthy let's give it a chance now
go fight for your family go fight for the world
in the world right now
i just threw a truck and a dragon i love my life
that looks like a blast that looks so fun
what was the m m song in the first trailer the
the first movie because they did an eminem song
and now they're doing uh oh man yeah and they're
doing this one it's gonna drive me crazy now
yeah i mean in terms of uh you know upgrade
from first movie to a sequel there's such a nice
visual quality aesthetic upgrade i do like that
it is exploring more of the god elements you got
hespera you got calypso something tells me that
you know like it looks like they're trying to
pitch helen mirren as the main villain but i
i'm more under the impression that because we
barely saw lucy liu that she's probably gonna be
more of the main villain uh this time around and
i like the setup that you have here for billy kind
of has like this imposter syndrome i just want to
point out like i was kind of shocked that they
showed us ben affleck's batman in this trailer
i know that he's live i know he's gonna be
showing up in the flash movie but i really
felt like dc has been at a point like we still
want you to like not think about that anymore
we don't want you to think about that i'm like
oh you just showed us it front and center in this
trailer i know he's going to be coming back up but
i was i was really taken aback by that but i like
the anyway back to the actual movie itself i do i
do like where they're setting up with billy even
feeling like he might not even belong with his
family right now such a strong part of him finding
family in the first movie and now it's like he
might feel like he he's not even needed with
his family as he's coming into like how old is
billy going to be in this movie he's an adult yet
like every i was thinking about the same thing
him and jack dylan grazer like all the young
people are going to look so much older now but
yeah what'd you think johnny i was really dazzled
by this like i'm really looking forward to this
a lot but yeah just the way this looks like it's
building upon the first movie both in terms of
david's f sandberg's just vision for it looks
way more dazzling and realized and for the dc eu
what i love about this is that it does incorporate
that sort of godly gravitas and they're dealing
with you know greek gods again like we just saw in
thor love and thunder and i love that this feels
a bit different like yeah it has the color and
it has the life and the fun but it also looks like
it's going to utilize the dc universe's particular
flavor for more menacing and more awe-inspiring
gods and and mythology and i love the kind of
blend that we see of that here i was such a
huge fan of the first film so i'm glad that
david f sandberg is you know he's bringing
back the comedy of course i think the i mean
for me just from this trailer the action looks so
much more grand than what we got i mean just it's
just a teaser trailer but what we got from the
first film this feels a lot like i said a lot
more grand and epic just in scope what what we've
seen so far i really like that they're tying again
back to the themes of the first film this family
and i love also too it's starting to get really
meta too when he was with helen mirren's like yeah
really men like family and then talking about fast
and furious i thought that was hysterical i mean
this looks like uh the david f sandberg's really
up in the andy in terms of comedy and action so
i'm really looking forward to that and then seeing
the two characters of hespera and uh and calypso
that looks really cool they look like they're uh
i mean again slight tease but you know gonna be
an interesting to see like in terms of the whole
shazam shazamly as you mentioned earlier you're
gonna see interesting gonna be formidable foes
that they're gonna be facing off with also too
uh they mentioned in the trailer that they are
the daughters of atlas and fun little fact that
i'm sure most of you already know the acronym for
shazam one of the letters and one of the words
in there is actually atlas the first one is
exactly they're all gods yeah the first one
seemed like it was kind of leaning into some
horror aspects i i doubt savannah's gonna return
in this god i'm liking on the caterpillar at
the end what's the name of that caterpillar i'm
flanking on the name mr mine mr mine got no hint
of him at all here i'm like they're just gonna
drop that there'll be another tease at the end
of this movie yeah just come back to mr mining
at the very end but it also seems like they're
setting up for some type of special dc cameo i'm
opting for wonder woman to appear in this film
out of all the cameos i feel like because of
the gods and stuff wonder woman seems like the
one that would appear in this film if they were
to get a dc cameo but only from the neck down we
were yeah and it won't be problematic for anyone
we don't really see freddie in this trailer we got
the rachel ziegler zeigler character uh we don't
get much of her so there's more to unpack with
this film as far as what we got so far i'm excited
for it this looks great this looks like a really
solid sequel follow-up man i love it it looks like
the ceo we should have gotten for big two and i
imagine that the parents one of them they gotta
find out like it seems like we're gonna get more
merry in the shazam lee now it seemed to have
an emphasis on her and i imagine that they'll
probably the parents will they got to find out
about losing one of these kids give him power
to give the parents her whole family oh yeah and
jamon hansu as the wizard is definitely getting
way more involved this time around it looks
like there's some type of personal connection
or vendetta that's between sparrow and calypso
uh in this film so yeah got a lot to unpack
what are you doing i
understood that reference dude
there's other stuff coming up and we've
talked for 15 minutes we got to get this done
all right thank you guys for being
here subscribe click that bell
leave a like shop zero edition.com
check out the shirts let's go